I really believe this is the beginning
of a sort of new wave of exploration in
the outer solar system we've got to
figure out how we go there more often
than every 20 or 30 years right we got
to figure out how we go there faster
[Music]
this is Star Talk
Cosmic queries Edition Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
and I got Chuck nice with me Chuck my
co-host what's happening Neil how are
you how you doing map So today we're
going to talk about the jet propulsion
Laboratories oh my gosh JBL JPL one of
the more storied places on Earth that's
been around even since before NASA yet
it is a branch of NASA and what brings
it gives it special attention today is
that it has a new director and I don't
mean to brag but like I'm personal
friends with the new director who
wouldn't even think of that yeah right
yeah so we're introduced Lori lesson
Laurie welcome to StarTalk thank you
Neil and Chuck it's so great to be with
you yeah you'd like spanking brand new
in that position just a few months you
know this is like we're starting out the
New Year 2023. yes happy New Year you
haven't been in there more than six
months or so right so just about six
months that's right well congratulations
how's it going so far good it's uh every
day is an adventure it's uh you know we
have weeks where it's like Mars on
Tuesday and Earth on Friday and it's uh
an astrophysics in between so we've got
all kinds of really exciting things
what's so Chuck you didn't ask the right
question it's Lori what debical did you
inherit yeah yeah there's that there's a
little bit of that a little bit of that
a little bit of that yeah so uh when I
arrived we were the first launch we were
supposed to do is a mission called
psyche which is a really cool Mission
which psyche is the name of the asteroid
right it is it's the name of the
asteroid and it's the name of the
mission because that's how we roll and
uh you know to keep everybody on their
toes wait which one are you talking
about
um but talking about the mission uh
turned out when I arrived about four
weeks later we realized we weren't quite
ready to launch and so we were going to
miss that one so
sure
well yeah so it's kind of the perfect
mission for that right like Lucy
football Lucy meet football there you go
yeah and now wait now this is super
interesting though because you're going
to a metal asteroid
we all know there's so many implications
kind of wrapped in that and what are you
guys going to do is it just going is it
what are you doing in orbit it's going
to go into orbit around this metal
asteroid and really map it we have never
visited a metal world right we've
visited Rocky worlds Mars Earth you know
other planets we have visited icy worlds
with the moons of Jupiter and Saturn and
the outer planets
um you know so-called you know icy
worlds or ocean worlds which we should
talk more about
um but we've never visited a metal world
that's because there actually aren't
that many of them yeah that's where Iron
Man comes from
it is also where Iron Maiden comes from
where the group yeah okay yeah that may
or may not be in her level one
requirements
so we are going so we're going to go
later this year we're going to we're
gonna launch it's not it's not exactly
it's not totally scratched it's not a
yeah in fact program and you know coven
had a lot to do with it honestly like
you can't you can't build spacecraft
from your parents basements like you
gotta you gotta be um we gotta be here
and be together and and we miss some
things and we needed to get that right
it's much having been involved in
missions that launched that weren't
ready to launch and that weren't
successful as a result it's much better
to sort of call a time out and say let's
do this right and that's what we've done
you can call time out on adults right
when your parent is saying to your kids
but your director yeah no we're not
putting them in a Timeout oh that's not
the football sorry we're calling it we
call the timeout to say we're not going
to launch if we're not ready and uh
let's go fix the issues which were
software issues it turns out Hardware's
doing great it's actually already in
Florida waiting for it's gonna launch on
a falcon heavy which is going to be
really rocking is SpaceX SpaceX Falcon
heavy so that's the one with three like
three Falcon 9 cores on it right it's a
big kick out to out to psyche so Lori
you're a geochemist so are you a
geologist that does chemistry or you're
a chemist that does geology how do what
do we think of you as this these two
professions stapled together in one time
yes that's exactly right I actually
studied chemistry as an undergraduate
and then sort of switched into Geo
science so I really do kind of sit at
the middle and I care a lot about life
in the universe but because I come from
a family of doctors my big rebellion in
life was I never took biology in college
so wow
that was like my big you know yes I did
the space part of this become
interesting to you for me it was I was a
10 year old girl seeing the very first
pictures from the surface of Mars from
the Viking missions way back in the 70s
and I grew up in Arizona and I think
there was just something about that
landscape that really spoke to me I
wanted to reach out and touch those
rocks and that has stayed has stayed
with me all these years and all these
years later I I get to we're working
right now to bring rocks back from Mars
not a very good uh advertisement for
Arizona
I think it's beautiful I disagree I saw
the surface of Mars and figured it's
I've got to get out of here every day I
get to look at new pictures from Mars
and they are yeah it reminds you home
yeah exactly I'm home
of course I'm going to end up probably
after I retire in Sedona which is about
as Mars like as you can get so yeah I
think it's just a thing for me and
what's your relationship with the Mars
Curiosity Rover
I am on a team I've actually been on the
Curiosity team since before it was even
called curiosity it's uh going all the
way back to the initial formulation of
the science goals I'm involved in two of
the instruments I was here at JPL well
before I worked for JPL I was here when
we landed on Mars I was actually on my
birthday in 2012 we landed on Mars with
curiosity awesome birthday present most
awesome birthday ever and uh yeah got to
have gotten to work on that our
discoveries around water on the uh in
the in the soil and the Rocks same
Mission still going ten years later
still going still going and so do you
get to set priorities for JPL or does
that come from up on high because you
presumably report to the the
administrative NASA the head of NASA and
the head of NASA I think reports to the
vice president right or someone in the
White House yeah what is it what's the
chain of command there how much autonomy
do they give you it's interesting
actually I mean there's a that's a
multifaceted question which I won't give
you the the long answer but first of all
were you unique among everyone knows
about NASA centers right Houston we have
a problem and we launched things from
from uh Florida at Kennedy Space Center
those are our government Labs where all
the employees are are government
employees we are actually a different
kind of a flavor of that we actually all
work for Caltech we're a federally
funded research and development center
and ffrdc we are the only
um NASA center that is such so so we
have a bit of a dual reporting
relationship where we get to sort of I
think our close connection with Caltech
a storied University that's great for
our our sort of innovation culture Lori
who signed your paycheck that's what we
want to is it
oh there it is but but all of the money
that funds us flows through NASA okay so
okay
multiple bosses shall we say okay so but
but really important that we align our
priorities with with NASA's and and also
that the inventions that we're investing
in and making help Drive NASA's
priorities right it's a bit of a two-way
street so we get to see kind of what's
up and coming where's the science going
and share that with the science
Community share it with NASA and that
helps Drive what missions NASA ends up
doing right so it's it's two-way it's
you also are duly appointed it's not
just that Caltech signs your check
you're actually affiliated with one of
the Departments there that's right I'm a
vice president of Caltech and I'm also a
professor at Caltech in my old PhD
department where I got my doctor at the
moment
they actually gave me an office on
campus it's my old grad student office
if you can believe that that's pretty
cool actually come back it's fine you
get to go back to your old department
and flexor muscles yeah that's pretty
awesome unfortunately this job takes a
lot of time so I don't have a ton of
time to spend on campus but um but the
connection to Caltech super important to
us you know excellent excellent and so
just before we get to our q a is there
um is there one or more or what's your
top goal for JPL in your in the tenure
that you're about to yeah I mean so it's
a really so much if it's about
delivering on our our really exciting
near-term portfolio we've got
um we just launched an earth the latest
earth science mission called SWAT which
is all about understanding Earth's water
we are working on oh my God I know right
what could be more important oh yeah
yeah
no you watch surface water ocean
topography
not special weapons and tactics okay no
okay surface water and and we're going
to launch psyche this year we're going
to launch a mission to Jupiter next year
that's going to focus on its icy Moon
Europa which is always get back to that
and we probably have questions on that
too but and then our sample return go to
Mars come back for the first time ever
that Mars round trip so delivering on
those messages is is our highest
priority
and come back and then get back that's
right no one-way trip here so echoink
Kurt Vonnegut Lori is this one of these
situations where you bring the sample
back from Mars and the last sentence
ever spoken oh no in the human species
is let's look inside
no I shouldn't laugh I'm not laughing
about that no we're taking it very
seriously as you know Neil planetary
protection is like a whole thing yeah
yeah and we're taking it really really
seriously that's giving you an excuse me
yeah yeah
protection you got people looking over
your shoulder to make sure what you
bring back is properly sealed and
contained exactly and boy you you should
see I mean uh I actually happen to have
here a model uh holding up on the video
part a model of one of the uh the sample
tubes each each sample is about the size
of your pinky so they're Little Rock
cores about size of your pinky and
they're drilled out which are then
sealed or drilled out sealed inside
things that's sealed inside that and
sealed inside something else I mean like
it's there's a lot of seals okay okay
we're gonna keep it safe
a sample wait no here it is so it's it
has Seven Seals
I'm resisting making seal no no no no no
and then she opens the seventh seal
right exactly you ushered in the entire
apocalypse there you go yeah so Chuck
you've got questions for for my friend
here indeed indeed we do I guess we'll
just and these are from our from our
patreon supporters yes they are yes very
cool for people who support you yeah
yeah
something uh something nice in return
for the people that support us so Pop
Warner we only have like a like a minute
left in this segment hello Dr Tyson Lord
nice Dr lesson does NASA have any plans
for future missions to Europa jumping
right into it the fact that the cold
frigid world might have an ocean of
water underneath is absolutely
fascinating what are the challenges of a
manned or even a robotic exploration of
Europa and what concerns might we have
for the potential of life in its Waters
my man has all gone he's gone
he was just like okay are we going how
are we going to get there and will it be
us will it be robots what about the fish
and if not yeah she goes all in and that
is a brilliant question all encompassing
that we will get to when we return from
this first break start talk
Cosmic queries with my good friend Lori
leschen recently appointed as the
Director of the jet propulsion
Laboratories Pasadena California stay
tuned
but we're backs in our talk Cosmic
queries all about the jet propulsion
Laboratories from the horse's mouth
itself Lori leshen recently arrested as
director of those labs in Pasadena
California and Lori uh I want my life as
an astrophysicist does not normally
overlap the lives of geochemists which
is what you are and we were just kind of
sort of merged together now 20 years ago
or so on a commission under then
President George W bush to study the
future of NASA and we were assembled we
were sort of hand-picked to bring all of
the NASA portfolio together at one table
right and so you're bringing in the
geology and I'm bringing in some Astro
we had some other folks we had an
Aeronautics person one of the A's and
NASA stands for Aeronautics so I I
greatly enjoyed a time together there
and the collaboration that represented
and and and dare I say I when I you were
just a lowly academic at the time but
you were like totally in charge of every
one of those meetings and I said damn
girl you know and the next time I turn
around you're like president of the
Worcester Polytechnic Institute and now
now head of of the jet propulsion labs
and I'm trying to think how many other
titles are left head of NASA okay there
you go ah
but you know I mean it's hard to believe
it's been almost 20 years yeah 20 years
and and that was a really transformative
professional experience for me and I
give you all the credit for my future
success after just I mean you were there
no I I it was already learning
experience for me I was a kid you don't
have to butter up the the host and you
can you're already a guest on the show
it's all true but it was my second
commission that's true yes I was the kid
I was the youngest of the nine
commission members and yeah it was a it
was a huge learning experience it was
clear that I said This Woman's gonna be
in charge of something one day that was
very clear but you're right we had a uh
didn't we have a four-star general Air
Force General we did General Isles yes
it was quite a pedigree incredible uh
incredible leaders across lots of parts
of government industry Academia yeah and
uh and it really showed me that like
broadening my perspective on things I
had been an academic my whole life and I
was feeling the Ivory Tower and and the
idea of
ditching my tenure and joining NASA
which I did soon after that
um was really uh
came from from that work yeah sometimes
it's a calling right and not literally a
phone call but
the universe beckons and you replied so
next we're glad to have you there so
thank you we're getting back to the
question that we dangled right in front
of all three of us what's the person's
name again Chuck that's Jonathan cull or
cool
k-u-hl okay
cool he's probably Jonathan cool cool
yeah I'll get the letter on social media
my name is Cool
Joe cool so tell us about Europa because
that question was all about everyone's
favorite moon of Jupiter it is
so exciting so literally right now as I
speak to you the our first dedicated
mission to Europa is sitting in our high
Bay in our big giant clean room here at
JPL being put together being assembled
and tested and it's called Europa
Clipper it's going to launch in October
of 2024. so just a quick question is is
that room this room you're describing is
that I've been in a room where an entire
wall was HEPA filters filters yes is
that what this wall is okay yes okay yes
exactly to keep it quite clean and
everybody in there is head to toe in
bunny suits as we call them to make sure
that you know none of our Schmutz gets
on the spacecraft right now you don't
want to discover the coronavirus on
Europa and say oh my gosh definitely not
bad oh no and then it's like somebody
anybody's hair somebody sneezed right
before right exactly yep
um and so we're in there putting that
spacecraft together it's going to go to
Jupiter it's actually going to go into
orbit around Jupiter but do multiple a
couple of dozen very close flybys to
Europa and with nine different sensors
that are gonna tell us about the ocean
underneath the ice about the thickness
of the eye so there's some places where
maybe the ice gets really thin if
there's stuff spewing out from the
surface we're going to analyze that with
them that would be fun crevasse
presumably or some kind of fried or some
kind of crack that's right yeah um how
thick are we talking here how thick
um many kilometers probably even tens of
kilometers thick in places how do you
want to see if there's water that's the
question right so if we can find some
spots where the ice is thinner that
helps you with the follow-up Mission
which should be a landed mission right
okay we don't have that approved yet but
we've been working on the technology to
make it possible to go land on a moon of
Jupiter mind-blowing are you kidding me
um by the way this is a solar powered
Mission at Jupiter you know Neil how
much further from right this one Jupiter
is then they are about five times
further right so the solar panels are
giant they would stretch from the toe to
the crown of the Statue of Liberty
so it's the biggest thing we've ever
built so Jupiter is five times farther
away so it's receiving 125th exactly
right of the summer intensity so if
you're gonna try to get the same power
you would have hanging out at Mars but
at Jupiter you're gonna have to your
panels have to be 25 times bigger bigger
and simple right wow so it's a it's a
per it's a beast it's a beast and then
the the spacecraft itself with nine
different sensors which of course the
scientists want all nine to be running
every time you fly by Europa so it's
quite complicated and the um radiation
environment at Jupiter is really harsh
and nasty which is one reason why
probably the surface of Europa is not a
very habitable environment but down in
the ocean you know who knows could there
be something weird
nice and you know so I heard and I've
seen close-up photos of the surface of
Europa where the where the ice looks
like it is cracked yes
yeah right so if it had cracked that
means water from below seeps up that's
right so to the surface and then freezes
again so could you have like
freeze-dried fish right there in those
cracks you could have freeze-dried
organic based something organic
right say it fish it's just pretty
Advanced I'd be happy without like cool
algae underneath the ocean and raise
your expectations yeah
all right at least crying serpents
Fields whatever you want Loch Ness
monster there you go oh that'd be cool
that'd be totally cool so that seems to
me that if you can't dig through
kilometers of ice you could at least
scoop up something from one of the
fissures exactly and so even from orbit
we think there is some outgassing going
on that we can we can look for organic
molecules and try and understand what's
happening there and then with a Lander
hopefully you can again dig into the
surface and and understand what's
happening so I I don't mean to brag but
I was in in I had a very brief cameo in
a movie called The Europa Report oh yes
yeah yeah so it's a movie and what they
did they just asked my permission to uh
quote me from a media interview that I
was in so I didn't have to like perform
for it uh and and they just got me
saying I want to go to Europa
dig through the
dig through at service and go ice
fishing
that's what I said nice and they like
that that's basically it yeah I think I
got like some good quotes for that that
was nice it's hard that's going to be a
challenge to get through that ice for
sure so we're already working on
technology to help us do that yeah so
that just just uh just to give a shout
out to the film it was like like an
indie budget kind of film and it was
called the Europa Report because they go
to Europa and the entire movie are just
Mission cameras positioned in the
cockpit and on the exterior of the
vessel and on the helmets of the crew so
every next Scene It says camera three on
camera seven and so that was like sort
of the the you had to buy into the fact
that this was a report given to Congress
to the sum of this Mission so it's an
interesting
um premise so so yeah people but when
science fiction is all up in your in
your situation you know you're on to an
interesting subject
it is and it's a one of of what we think
now are many what we would call Ocean
worlds in the outer solar system back
when you and I were growing up in
science Neil that we were not thinking
about habitable environments that far
from the sun right well certainly not on
moons moons were like who cares about
moons that's right the planets
themselves and the whole other world so
it's it's the beginning I really believe
this is the beginning of a sort of new
wave of exploration in the outer solar
system we've got to figure out how we go
there more often than every 20 or 30
years right we got to figure out how we
go there faster I'm a little older than
you to put it in context when I was when
we were first going out to the solar
system everything was a flyby yeah right
no one went into orbit around the planet
so we did the scores of this Voyager was
Voyager One Two Pioneer 10 and 11. still
going all just flybys so you had to like
get your camera ready you know right
right
so Chuck give me some more more
questions all right let's keep it going
let's keep it going let's go with
Fernando uh Cologne who says this uh Dr
lesson greetings from San Diego my
question is simple now with the
achievement of fusion ignition uh at the
Lawrenceville National Laboratory will
Fusion Energy play a role in space
travel and if so how long will it take
until it becomes viable as a main energy
source for Rockets I love it I love it
let's get this done yeah yeah that's
what he's saying so so that's a great
question I mean it's a huge
congratulations to the the nif team up
up at Livermore that that is a huge
achievement and it's like step one yeah
0.1 on the road to doing what
um what is being asked about because it
got a long way to go to try and get that
scaled uh but but you got to start
somewhere and and they've been working
towards this milestone for years so
congrats to them in space we now use
vision and energy we do use nuclear
energy but it's it's of a different kind
right we use radioactive uh um things
like the synonym that actually produce
energy when they split apart into other
atoms so that is today available to us
and we in fact use it extensively our
Mars rovers use it we use it out Beyond
Jupiter you really can't do solar power
so we we've used it on missions like
Cassini and Saturn but but you're
getting that energy a little bit for
free because the the plutonium naturally
decays can you just send the plutonium
and the and the blob of it gets hot and
then the thing the hard part about that
is just concentrating the plutonium
right yeah yeah that's right out and get
it ready but you don't need those are
not sitting in a nuclear reactor they're
just their own things that's right so
now but with a fusion it seems like you
gotta you gotta get that to happen on
your own yeah I mean I think it's going
to be be a while it's the honest answer
to the question yes
nobody quite knows how to scale me on
the little tiny bit that they were able
to do yet but but you got to start
somewhere and uh and the sun knows how
to do it so you know yes son never had
any trouble making that happen yeah so
Chuck time for another wave keep going
here we go this is Allen of Wales
and so Alan says uh Dr Tyson Dr lesson
and Chuck uh it is amazing to see the
space launch system successfully orbit
the Orion capsule and to see it safely
return to Earth but really what grounds
does NASA have to continue to build
expandable launch systems agreed massive
profits no doubt made supplying this
one-time throwaway equipment but does
NASA have any plans to build reusable
systems like commercial companies have
already successfully deployed
well Lori said she's not using a NASA
vessel she's that's right
yeah right how much are the Falcon heavy
is reusable
so it depends on what you're launching
so in some cases they actually will fly
um like two of the boosters back uh
they've done that with Heavies in some
cases you want
to take every last bit of fuel out of
that reusable rocket and so you actually
use it in an Expendable mode so that's
an option for us as well
um so yeah just to be clear in case
people don't realize if you're going to
bring the boosters back yeah you gotta
leave some fuel you launched them with
fuel yeah that did not participate in
continuing to send your payload to its
destination so so you're using up weight
in order to bring the thing back so it's
quite the interesting economic trade-off
there right between the reusability and
the cost of your mission
but I think um you know I think Artemis
was a huge success and it's just great
to see that launched I mean in some ways
that program saw its origin from the
from the work that Neil and I did
together oh yeah and the commitment back
in the day right about what's going to
come after the shuttle on the future the
U.S
um space exploration program right so
we're proud to see that flying right
right nice little humble brag happening
right okay take a little credit yeah
there you go
all right Chuck slipping another
question before we go to break all right
here we go uh this is Adam Akra who says
this hello Dr Laurie Neal and Mr Nice
I've always been fascinated by the
thought of going to another planet do
you think that this is feasible in our
lifetimes well Adam we don't know how
old you are but
if he's 89. the answer is no he says at
least at the a minimum to see another
human being make it to Mars and for your
reference I'm 50 years old okay okay
JPL is completely
um robotic robotic right so you could
you could say we're already on Mars we
are yes you resize her over but um so do
we need people on Mars are you ready
what do you do with people and do we do
the people learn anything from all of
your efforts and orbital trajectories
and 100 inserts to how much shared uh
insights are is there between those yeah
100 I mean if you look at the history of
JPL I mean there's a lot of ways to
answer this but one of the our very
first you know worries into deep space
was on missions like Ranger and surveyor
which paved the way for astronauts to go
to the Moon 50 years ago of course yes
and so we and today that that way for
those who don't know those two missions
a photographed in high detail the
surface of the Moon correct so that we
could judge what might be the best place
to land we had no idea no idea
we just tried to crash it in we missed a
bunch of times by the way we literally
like whoops miss the moon darn it and
and
there's a lot of good stories around
here you want to land safely plus you
want to land where there's some
interesting geology right otherwise
that's right what's the point right well
we didn't even know you know where the
Lander's gonna sink into the lunar dust
like there was all kinds of stuff with
basic stuff and and our Rovers on Mars
are and Landers are Paving the way today
um for human exploration and Mars sample
return which is actually going to be the
first mission to make the round trip to
Mars is a big one and you know actually
launching something from the surface of
Mars that comes back to earth right so
so we're absolutely Paving the way I'm
optimistic that uh in was it Adam I'm
sorry Adam's lifetime that's right that
uh that we will see people on Mars and
and I'm bullish on what they can do as a
geologist if we look at what one of our
Rovers does in a day and they've
actually done some tests around this a
human could do that in a minute or two
right kind of go somewhere look around a
bit try to figure it's it's how fast the
Rovers grow
oh you know curiosity goes about as fast
as a human can walk so it's reasonable
but not very fast
um perseverance who's there now is is a
bit zippier so can go a little bit
faster it's still going to be slow on
like it's not race car time right yeah
Rover races that's how you know where in
the future it also depends it also
depends what kind of human you're
comparing it to okay
so I'm hopeful Laurie we've got to take
a break but when we come back we'll
continue and we might even go into a
lightning round Cosmic queries on Star
talk with the freshly minted director of
the Japan pulsion Laboratories Lori
lesson we'll be right back
we're back start talk Cosmic queries
Neil deGrasse Tyson here we've got the
newly minted head director of the jet
propulsion laboratory is a branch of
NASA which is a also in a way a branch
of the California Institute of
Technology Caltech in Pasadena
California ensuring that it has an
unending uh access
to academic Excellence so Brilliance
that that Caltech Only Knows is academic
Excellence so so Lori is
um do they let you jump onto social
media all by yourself or do you have to
vet what you post because if people want
to follow what you do how do they do
that I am at Lori of Mars on Twitter
Laurie what Lori of Mars Maury of Mars
that is my Twitter handle
I'm still on Twitter I'm like
hopeful you can get bumped off okay yes
no yeah uh and yeah and then there's a
ton of JPL social media too on almost
every platform you can imagine and so
what's jpl's handle
at NASA JPL NASA JPL okay yeah
then there's all lots of our missions
are tweeting uh you know uh actually
Mars Insight is a good example we just
came to the end of mission of Mars
Insight recently and it put out kind of
a last tweet my power's getting low I
mean honestly experience the first
person because it does so so of
exploring Mars our our uh our rovers are
tweeting there you go Mark Watney we're
coming for you yeah
yeah always hard to see one come to an
end even though it lasted far outlasted
its uh its Mission it's expiration date
yeah so Chuck let's maybe do a lightning
round this segment so sure you just have
to answer quickly okay and shut me up if
I interrupt okay so Chuck good all right
our friend Kevin the sommelier says
congratulations Dr lesson on your
directorship
having a background in geochemistry I'm
sure the asteroids and comments are of
great interest to you How likely is it
to capture one in the harness its
resources within the next 25 years and
to celebrate your new role I would
recommend a bottle of Lauren Perrier
Rose
yeah
it's a sparkling wine it says sparkling
rose yeah it's a sport and so I love
that it would be Rose because it's made
from the Pinot Noir grape but not left
too far in contact with the skin yeah
I'm a huge fan of the Brut Rose
he's a great parent he's a great Samuel
yeah he he knew this without even
meeting you yeah exactly that's
fantastic perfect come I could use a
personal assembly no I was actually
married to one
that's good hey um asteroid so you know
yeah when are we going to get rich off
asteroids oh look I think um nearest
asteroids exploring them for resources
and learning to live more off the land
out in Space is really important to keep
pursuing it's um it's a huge Challenge
25 years is probably about the right
kind of time frame to be thinking about
okay and how about comets is there any
value to the water that's on them
why am I you know we don't know enough
about the surface of comets yet but but
um probably somewhat less valuable would
be my initial relative to the to the uh
the metals and minerals
unless you're thirsty in space then I
always want some water that's true yeah
or just bring some Brut Rose
or you do what they do on the space
station just recycle your pee okay we'll
be doing that that's a whole different
kind of rosette it's a different
question
all right Chuck keep it coming all right
thank you our friend y Coss says this
with quite an attitude I might admit uh
from the Russian Luna and two three
missions in 1959 when it landed it
crashed and orbited the moon and the
manned Apollo program in the 60s uh to
the Chinese
uh uh Changi five uh Capstone Orbiter
and the Korean uh der Nori Orbiter there
have been many many moon missions
what makes the Artemis program so
particularly interesting
well I think the goal of Artemis and
again JPL isn't doesn't
we're involved we did all the
communications with Orion once it went
beyond uh near Earth
for NASA
um so we are the ones who are talking to
Iran those beautiful pictures you saw
coming back of the Earth and Moon those
came through our DC's network but the
goal of Iran is that content is that um
you know the presence that isn't just
about flags and footsteps it's about
learning to really live on other worlds
and none of those robotic missions have
done that and really to have a sustained
presence out in the solar system the
Moon is a great training ground yeah the
blunt answer is Artemis is putting
people back on the moon is a robot so
you know people yeah there you have it
yeah
yeah he was coming at it that was a
great answer all right all right this is
Christopher Bax he says howdy everybody
my question is about the future of
spacecraft propulsion are there any
promising new technologies and
development that you think will
revolutionize people future space
missions so Fusion we've agreed is
pretty far off at least as imaginary
solution but anything but NASA's been
involved in some stuff right
sure I mean you know we're continuing to
do more things like solar electric
propulsion
um there actually is we're testing some
green propulsion Technologies on one of
our very small lunar robotic missions
that we just launched called lunar
flashlight that you know I think that's
an interesting thing to think about uh
especially with the number of launches
that that we're doing as a as a planet
is that a smaller sale no it's not it's
different kind of uh chemical propulsion
okay which is I think as much as I know
okay rocks I study rocks
that's hilarious stationary rocks yeah
okay
no but the point is that NASA does
presumably have an entire uh sub
industry within itself thinking about
propulsion you bet you bet right
absolutely we work a lot on solar
electric footballs all right there you
go Christopher your answer is we're
working on it all right so uh this is
Corey Allen
says hello Dr lesson this is Corey from
Minneapolis
um if we park the satellite with a
high-powered laser in orbit around an
icy moon like Europa or even Enceladus
could the laser burn a hole into the
surface in which a small probe could be
dropped would this not be easier and
less intrusive than drilling into the
ice thank you all love the show uh first
of all let me just say this Corey you
would make a great Bond villain
space laser space laser lasers at the
laser yeah
um yeah so the interesting so good one
Corey thank you very creative and we we
love those kind of creative ideas at JPL
we like to think about them turns out
getting through the ice at a place like
Europa is really hard because it tends
to want to close up on itself right and
so you need something that's going to
kind of hold open the hole once you
you've made it just like on earth when
they are drilling they they put casing
inside the hole right and and doing that
down through lots of deep ice is hard so
a from space solution there I don't
think would work I'd have to think about
it a little bit more but I love the
creativity yeah I'd like that Lori the
way you said that because thinking about
it in real time you could milk the top
a little bit like let's say a few
centimeters and there's a little puddle
right but it wants to refreeze so you
have to keep heating it to prevent that
from refreezing while you melt the next
few centimeters right right and now that
you got that melted you need the heat to
keep that liquid while you melt the next
few centimeters so I don't know if it's
just a single laser pointing down would
accomplish this right because you're
fighting against nature which just wants
to freeze the whole damn thing over
right and just and once you get deep
enough the pressure you know it just
wants to close up on itself so right
right we actually have some some
colleagues in Caltech working on this it
turns out to be a really challenging
problem yeah you need a perfectly
vertical
um lightsaber that's what you need
lightsaber just let it keep going down
all right
um take it Messier says this hello Lori
Neil and our personal ha ha physicist
don't do that
uh Tegan here from British Columbia I
was wondering since gravity affects
light how does the Earth's gravitational
field not affect the way we see Earth
looking from outside of our own
gravitational field and vice versa from
inside gravity when we're looking from
another planet so that sounds like a
nail question
Earth as big and as massive as it is it
it is vanishingly small in its effect on
gravity gravity and its effect on the
light in its vicinity to not have that
matter at all to either we looking out
from Earth where people from outside
Earth looking in as we start getting
more and more dense and massive like
towards a black hole then it completely
distorts the visual environment not only
looking out but also looking in but so
so yes that happens but you have to be
way more massive massive than Earth is
so yeah don't worry about it yeah wow
great answer oh cool cool cool all right
thanks for thanks for jumping in on that
one
I got your back
I got your back Lori okay all right
here's Stephen Smith Steven Smith man we
are we are moving along this is the
fastest lightning round we've ever had
okay
I knew that we knew that it still got me
back yeah Steven Smith says this hey
y'all it's Steve here from just outside
Dr Laurie has there been any progress in
creating an ion space engine
for interplanetary so which is pretty
cool yeah I don't know about the engine
side but we are thinking a lot about
missions that go beyond the solar system
I do think it's on the frontier I think
you'll see in the coming year
um you know more discussion about that
and of course I have to use this
opportunity to give a shout out to our
Interstellar voyagers Voyager right the
Voyager missions are on the edge of the
solar system right now they're the
farthest human-made thing that's that
has ever been sent anywhere and we still
talk to them every single day
I thought they started they lost 45
years ago wow there are going to be 50
in another four years or so so sweet and
and they are still going they got that
golden record on their Neil you know
about it right and and uh if if any
aliens are out there you know spinning
the disc they'll find out about us so
yeah we Interstellar travel I think is
um you know Interstellar exploration is
definitely on the forward okay by the
way but the question actually asked
interplanetary but I think they meant
Interstellar interesting oh that is how
I interpreted it yeah
the interplanetary is cool and I just
love the idea of the uh aliens finding
that disc and playing it and going this
is the worst damn album I have ever
heard I happen to have a record player
right here
because on the on the albums like Mozart
Beethoven Heartbeats The Chuck Berry was
on there there's a it's a melange of
human culture and Senate
back in the 70s where the aliens found
the ship and sent a message back to the
White House and the president reads it
Mr President what did the alien say and
it says send more Chuck berries oh
that's right that's right totally Dr
Perry actually came and played on the
steps right outside my building here at
JPL yes yes in the 80s yeah it's a
celebration of that yeah yeah yeah damn
that's so cool yeah right yeah all right
Chuck maybe time for like one more one
more and it comes from our friend
Alejandro Reynoso okay wow good boys
Chuck he says
I'm just easy better the fact that he
keeps writing back means he's not
offended by what I did but anyway it's
irregular back to it yeah
from Monterrey Mexico okay he says
hello
or should I say oh my God
my question is what is the most
important thing that you are working on
that we do not know about
oh I'd love that question
okay what a great question here it is I
I have two I'll be really really fast
that because everybody knows about our
Mars rovers and all the cool planetary
stuff we do but we also do amazing
things in astrophysics we are building
the first major coronagraph an
instrument that's going to block the
light of stars so we can image planets
around them that will launch on the next
big Space Telescope called the Nancy
Grace Roman Space Telescope named after
women woo and um and the other thing you
we do a ton just to be clear all of our
knowledge of exoplanets comes from their
influence on the host star or because
they blocked out right and so but we
don't want pictures of them we don't
actually see them so you're saying
you're going to build a a telescope that
is taking light away so that you're not
you can image the planet's not lost in
the glare correct the size of a grand
piano this thing it's amazing so and
then the other big thing we do that I
really want to mention is Earth science
eyes on Earth we are driving the future
techno analogy that helps us measure and
understand where our foam planet is
headed and we care really deeply about
that as well and so we've got a lot of
New Missions coming up in earth science
whether it's working on aerosols and
their connection to asthma or looking at
the radiation budget at the polls or
understanding you know earthquakes and
biomass and then we just launched of
course SWAT to look at Earth's water wow
very cool excellent so look okay now
tell us uh what's classified we want to
hear that too I I could tell you but I'd
have to kill you it's not going to work
but we won't tell anybody we're just
just our just our fan base that's all we
can we can all keep a secret that is the
sweetest way I've ever heard anybody say
I'll have to kill you
like your tone is like you know it was
so inviting yeah it was so loving yes
yeah I'll kill you dear yeah you're a
dangerous woman Lori
new comment so Lori thanks for being on
Star Talk oh my gosh and we wanted to
get you right when you started and then
I realized retrospectively how bad an
idea that was because you're just trying
to get up and running and so catching up
with you six months later in the New
Year 2023
um we look forward to all that you will
bring to the jet propulsion Labs
maintaining and extending the Legacy
that is so storied for that institution
so uh we're thrilled to be with you yeah
thanks it's been a delight once again
and uh Lori we'll try to can we have
like a a red phone hotline to your
office for like if something else
happens in the future you can like
so as long as I can have a personal
astrophysicist line where I can call you
when I get
two ways my friend two ways no it's just
that you feel does we all know JPL does
the coolest stuff and we don't want to
be too far from it we do we know we're
not because you're there so all right
thanks this has been Star Talk Cosmic
queries Edition all about JPL past
present and future
featuring Lori lesson it's New Direction
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist has always been
used
foreign
[Music]